when I have a tremendous amount of work
to do and I don't have a lot of time to
do it make the list first then I ascribe
the amount of time that I think it
should take me to do it if I'm very
focused and then once I have all the
times I block similar types of work
together and then from there I will put
them on my calendar with the supposed
time block Parkinson's law states that
work expands to the time a lot if you
just say I'm going to work on this today
it will take the entire day and so
having the time boxes allows you to be
more focused and have a deadline
constraints Drive Innovation constraints
drive performance and so for me boxing
my time once I have my priorities has
been the easiest way to get the most out
of my day